you mentioned uh to jump around a little
bit the First Amendment first of all
what is the first amendment and what is
the connection to you between
the First Amendment the freedom of
speech and cancer culture sure
so I'm a First Amendment lawyer as I
mentioned and that's what I uh that's my
passion that's what I studied and I
think American First Amendment law is
incredibly interesting in one sentence
the first amendment is trying to get rid
of basically all the reasons why
humankind had been killing each other
for its entire existence that we weren't
going to fight anymore over opinion we
weren't going to fight any more of
religion that you have the right to
approach your government for redressing
grievances um that you you have the
freedom to associate that all of these
things in one sentence were like nope
the government will no longer interfere
with you with uh with your right to have
these have these fundamental human uh
human rights and so one thing that makes
fire a little different from other
organizations is is however we're not
just a First Amendment organization we
are a free speech organization and so uh
and and but at the same time a lot of
what I think free speech is can be well
explained with reference to a lot of
First Amendment law partially because in
in American history some of our smartest
people have been thinking about what the
parameters of freedom of speech are
um in relationship to the First
Amendment and a lot of those principles
they they transfer very well just as as
pragmatic ideas so like the biggest sin
in terms of censorship is called
Viewpoint discrimination that
essentially you allow freedom of speech
except for that opinion now it's and
it's found to be kind of more defensible
and I think this makes sense that if if
you set up a forum and like we're only
going to talk about economics to exclude
people who want to talk about a
different topic but it's considered
rightfully
um a bigger deal if you've set up before
and from economics but we're not going
to let people talk about that kind of
Economics or have that opinion on
economics what most most particularly so
a lot of the principles from First
Amendment law actually make a lot of
philosophical sense as good principles
for when like what is protected and
unprotected speech what should get you
in trouble how you actually analyze it
which is why we actually try in our
definition of cancel culture to work in
some of the First Amendment Norms just
in the definition so we don't have to
bog down on them as well you're saying
so many interesting things but if you
can link on the Viewpoint discrimination
is there any gray area of discussion
there like what isn't isn't economics
for the example you gave yeah is it is
there uh I mean is it a science does it
or is it an R to draw lines of what is
and isn't allowed yeah you know if
you're saying that something is or is
not economics well you can say
everything's economics and therefore I
want to talk about poetry there'd be
some line drawing exercise in there but
let's say you at once you decide to open
up
um uh it's a poetry even
um it's a big difference between saying
okay now we're open to poetry uh but you
can't say you know Dante was bad
um like that's a that's a forbidden
opinion now officially in in this
otherwise open Forum that would
immediately at an intuitive level strike
people as a bigger problem than just
saying that poetry isn't economics yeah
I mean that intuitive level that you
speak to
I hope
that all of us have that kind of basic
intuition when the line is crossed it's
the same thing for like pornography yeah
you know when you see it I think there's
the same level of intuition that should
be applied across the board here
um and it's when that intuition becomes
deformed by whatever forces of society
that's when it starts to feel like
censorship yeah I mean people find it a
different thing
um you know if someone loses their job
simply for their political opinion even
if that employer has every right in the
world to fire you I think Americans
should still be like well it's true they
have every right in the world and I'm
not making a legal case that maybe you
shouldn't
fire someone for their political opinion
but think that through like what what
Society do we want to what kind of
society do we want to live in and it's
been funny watching
um you know and I I point this out yes I
will defend businesses uh First
Amendment rights of Association to be
able to have the legal right to decide
you know who works for them
um but from a moral or philosophical
matter
if you think through the implications of
if every business in America becomes an
expressive Association in addition to
being a profit maximizing organization
that would be a disaster for democracy
because you would end up in a situation
where people would actually be saying to
themselves I don't think I can actually
say what I really think and and still
believe I can keep my job and that's
where I was worried I felt like we were
headed because a lot of the initial
response to people getting canceled
um was uh very simply
um you know oh but they have the right
to get rid of this person
um and that and and that's that's the
end and be beginning and end of the
discussion and I thought that was a
Dodge I thought that wasn't actually a
very serious way if that if you care
about both the First Amendment and
freedom of speech of thinking it through
so to you just uh
clarify the first amendment is kind of
a legal embodiment of the ideal of
freedom of speech and then Freedom
despite the government in this very
specific applied to government and
freedom of speech is the application of
the principle to like everything
including like kind of the high level
philosophical ideal of what it of the
value of people being able to speak
their mind yeah it's an older Bolder
more expansive idea and you can have a
situation uh and I talk about countries
that have good free speech law but not
necessarily great Free Speech culture
and I talk about how when we sometimes
make this distinction between Free
Speech law and Free Speech culture we're
thinking in a very cloudy kind of way
um and what I mean by that is that laws
generally particularly in a common law
country it's the reflection of norms
those you know judges are people too and
in a lot of cases common law is supposed
to actually take our intuitive ideas of
fairness and and place them you know
into the law so if you actually have a
culture that doesn't appreciate free
sweet from a philosophical standpoint
um it's not going to be able to protect
free speech for the Long Haul even in
the law because eventually that's one of
the reasons why I worry so much about
some of these terrible cases coming out
of law schools
um because I I fear that even though
sure American First Amendment law is
very strongly protective of First
Amendment for now it's not going to stay
that way if you have generations of law
students
um graduating who actually think there's
nothing there's no higher goal than
shouting down you're an opponent yeah so
that's why so much of your focus
uh or a large fraction of your focus is
on the higher education or education
period is because education
is the foundation of culture yeah you
have this history you know uh 64. you
have the free speech movement on
Berkeley and in uh 65 you have
repressive tolerance by Herbert Marcus
which was a declaration of by the way
um we on the left we shouldn't we should
have Free Speech but we should have free
speech for us I mean I I went went back
and reread
um uh repressive tolerance and how clear
it is I I forgot I had forgotten that it
really is kind of like um and these
so-called conservatives and
right-wingers we need to repress them
because they're regressive thinkers it
really doesn't come out to anything more
sophisticated than the very old idea
um that our people are good they get
free speech we should they should keep
it
other side bad
um we should not have and we have to
retrain society and of course like it it
ends up being another he was also a fan
of Mao so it's not surprising that he
that of course the system would have to
rely on some kind of totalitarian
uh system but that was a laughable
um uh position you know uh say 30 40
years ago the the idea that essentially
you know free speech for me not for the
uh as the great you know Free Speech
Champion that hentov used to say was
something that you were supposed to be
embarrassed by but I saw this when I was
in in law school in 97 I saw this when I
was interning at the ACLU in 99
um that there was a slow motion train
wreck coming that essentially there was
um these bad ideas from campus that had
been
taking on more and more steam of
basically no free speech for my opponent
we're actually becoming more more and
more accepted as and partially because
Academia was becoming less and less
Viewpoint diverse I think that as my
co-author Jonathan height points out
that when you have low Viewpoint
diversity people start thinking in a
very kind of tribal way and if you don't
have the respected descenders you don't
have the people that you can point to
that I'm like hey this is a smart person
um this is like this is a smart
reasonable decent person that I that I
disagree with so I guess not everyone
thinks alike on this issue you start
getting much more kind of like only you
know only bad people only Heretics only
blasphemers only right Wingers you know
um can actually think in this way